the director of ADF did this thing and
they were like defined in 15 seconds for
me an assault weapon and he was like
well I'm not a gun expert so I can't and
one of my favorite tweets that came out
of her was I think was a guy named
George Costas he said he doesn't know
anything about Firearms I'm glad he
admitted that does he know a lot about
alcohol and tobacco what does this guy
do yeah right yeah it's like name your
favorite booze oh look I'm not a drinker
I don't know like well I am not an
expert that's the kind of person uh
Budweiser should hire though that's
right gosh and then tobacco that's just
but he's also can we get rid of this
agency it makes no sense okay there's a
problem with that there's actually a
problem
yeah uh because I was talking to someone
at the ATF a few weeks ago you know
Inside Man just getting some information
and we're they don't like the FBI nobody
likes the FBI I don't think anyone in
America if you were sitting in a bar and
a guy you said hey what do you do for at
work and he said I'm worth the FBI
if an FBI agent come to me like I'm with
the FBI to go oh yeah X-Files I beg
really tell me everything yeah I know
only like that guy who's in bones and
helps her with her cases he's cool yeah
but the FBI agents we like I guess the
average American will thank an FBI agent
for their service they're not going to
do that not right now but uh so I saw it
in my ATF guy and uh we were talking
about
um shoot where was I going uh the brace
thing where we just talk about us
abolishing the ATF aboluction ATF and I
and so I asked him about that and he
said well the problem with the ATF going
away is the FBI would take over
resources they're weaponized way more
easily by the administration like
technically it's they've been trying to
weaponize the ATF for political means
and it's they put through an executive
order I think in 2021 it's still not in
effect this year that's how slow moving
the ATF is which is good for us like I
actually don't mind that's pretty cool
so my my tweet was essentially the ATF
should get removed when the gun laws are
removed at the same time so the FBI
can't do anything Squirrely and weird
and as long as you're I mean it's not
really that tall of an order to get rid
of federal gun laws because the federal
government doesn't have extensive gun
laws thanks to the Second Amendment
there's really limits placed on what the
feds can actually but here here's here's
the most important question the ATF has
just imposed a rule yep without without
Congress making it illegal to own an
item attached to to a weapon that will
make what hundreds of thousands of
people criminalize millions millions and
millions and millions I can't remember
what that number was it was like three
three we uh we we I I had to have them
uh because I think I have a handful of
pistols with braces they're all removed
and separated and stored somewhere far
away I just got Bob stocks and
everything man
but so but but with that are you still
allowed to have them so long as they're
not attached uh no the whole bumps out
things okay this is oh they lost that
they lost it right but no one knows like
it's in limbo and like will the company
starts selling them again no probably
not because they're like well they'll
just ban it the court struck that down
that is correct and the the brace thing
is going to be the exact same thing
they're going to fight it for two years
the issue is for resellers like gun
broker for example the day that went out
or the next day that went out they
pulled all those things of guns with
braces off of their website let's let me
provide people with some context real
quick just because it may be a little
bit esoteric for a lot of people and
there are uh pistols and there are
people who are disabled in order to fire
the pistol they attach a brace which
goes onto your forearm so you can hold
it however some of they they can adjust
in length they're retractable and so
some people and they and these are bad
people I tell you horrible they pushed
it up to their shoulder to simulate a
stock because a brace can simulate a
stock they've now made it illegal or
they've just issued a short build rifle
yeah essentially they've decreed it now
that's that's the biggest problem I've
said on the shows like come on we know
people are using braces like stocks it's
like everyone right right everybody
knows but and so I if first of all I
disagree with all the gun control but if
it went through Congress I'd roll my
eyes I'd complain about it but this is a
hundred times worse than the rose agency
a rogue agency issuing a rule we hereby
decree that if you have this thing
you're a felon that's crazy yep and the
issue is most people aren't following
the news I mean they just don't want to
they want to go about their life work
their job do whatever they don't know
what's going on with every regulation
and then all of a sudden a dude a little
bit caught up and I'll be like well I
didn't know it got changed I didn't
realize y'all were changing laws every
three years and regulations
right yeah but they said braces are fine
like you can do this thing they you know
SB sent this product to them they said
that's fine and so everyone bought them
and then oh you're gonna change your
mind on it and go back on it and that's
going to screw over all the people that
don't pay attention to loss because I
mean I have a hard time paying attention
I literally do this for a job keeping up
with all the regulations I mean I'm
probably a felon five days out of the
week if I if I didn't cover the news
there's no way I would have known about
this no and so sure enough when the news
comes out it's like okay we gotta go and
I think I think I like three and we we
took them off and we moved them and
started somewhere else I mean I am you
know I'm a guy that shoots a lot and I
paid a lot of attention to guns and I'm
you know active in the gun world and at
least enough to be aware of what's going
on and to think that the average person
is going to do that kind of stuff when
they've got they've got a family they've
got work they've got kids they've got
all an election coming up they're like
okay what do I do it's like they're
they're normal people with normal lives
and that's something that I think a lot
of people that that are are wrapped up
in this kind of stuff don't realize your
average person doesn't spend their days
paying attention to the details about
what you know what laws or whatever and
when you can go to you know you can go
to like Runnings in New England there's
this this uh it's essentially Tractor
Supply that sells guns as well but you
can buy a you know a 10 inch pistol or
you could buy a 10 inch pistol and you
know some dude just goes and he's like
oh I can pick this up for 1500 bucks go
home and I shoot it once in a while that
doesn't watch gun tube stuff and he
doesn't know that he's now a felon or
he's going to be a felon or whatever you
see uh you know that's ridiculous you
said a viral video of that gen Z
Democrat where he was like we're coming
for your guts we're gonna win we're
gonna take them we're not tired by the
White House
no no he's hired by the White House no
no I was gonna say you should invite him
to your house I I'll take him to the
range I mean I'll have to have some
people there so I don't get like Chris
Kyle but I tweeted uh they already lost
oh the the gun control people oh yeah
not only are we looking at 27
constitutional carry states I think
Nebraska and Florida are next to go into
effect yep but 3D printed guns exist
it's done there's nothing I can do about
it the the uh the well I won't say what
I was gonna say I was gonna say ammo so
they try to go off your ammo years ago
green tip ammo that's honestly yes a
steel penetrator uh it's all right it's
not that great but um but it works but
they tried to go after ammo and the
thing that gun control you know people
could do if they were they were smart is
they would go after
um they would use OSHA compliance and
they would try to shut down businesses
and make it harder for businesses to
function businesses would have to raise
the prices to offset that I know but I'm
telling everyone who's on here who needs
to understand these things because I run
a business I can actually talk about
this
um that's how they could actually shut
down a lot of people from owning guns
and make it so only people in like the
six income you know six figure income
bracket could actually afford guns that
would be the way to do it because you're
they're not going to actually ban
weapons anytime soon but in States like
Washington I mean they just did and now
that's being fought so in some of the
really blue States like super blue
States I think we will see those bands
like at least be in effect for another
10 20 years until culture can shift and
change but nationally it's not going to
happen I just I just want to point out
like it's kind of amazing that we are
winning this this well like gun for one
something yeah gun rights are winning so
tremendously it's like not even a
contest it's never been popular in
America no matter how much the media
says it's never been popular when you
get down to the individual level to take
guns away if you talk wait wait it
wasn't until I think like 2008 with uh
was it Heller in DC that then people
were actually able to have guns legally
Nationwide
good we had in the 80s Most states would
not give you a gun permit right you
couldn't have guns and then you watch
around the year 2000 constitutional
carry starts popping up state by state
and now it's 27 States yep so Nebraska
so it's 25 in effect Florida adjusted
permitless concealed carry Nebraska I
think went full constitutional am I
wrong just today I think it was and and
more coming it ain't over here more and
more states are going to implement I
think uh the the big the big Frontier is
going to be
and the issue right now is the federal
government still controls who gets to
sell guns that is the whole FFL whole
thing the gun control act or whatever it
was that is the actual like the final
frontier of getting rights back is when
can States just get to do it on their
own you could have their own system for
choose
Amendment violation yeah did States ever
get to control who who actually on time
not up on my gun history I think back in
the day they took guns to schools yeah
like people a lot of people that are
anti-gun will sit there and they'll say
well you never had this right you never
had that right etc etc but that's that's
essentially spinning reality on its head
because the idea that you were
prohibited was foreign to a free people
if you are by your nature free then the
idea that you don't have this right is
completely foreign to the concept of you
being free it comes with your Liberty
the fact that you're free means you
don't have to ask permission and that
doesn't matter what the context is you
know and it's so the idea that oh you
know you only the government is creating
this right and Etc no no no no no the
government doesn't create Liberties
Liberties exist and then the only thing
the government can do is infringe upon
those which the Second Amendment is
ostensibly supposed to prevent which it
does a poor job of it might right
although it did help with the Bruin case
it did they did go back to that and go
hey according to this thing you know in
order to pass regulations you can't just
say it's for Public Safety because you
can't actually you can't argue that so
like you can't do it anymore the bump
stock thing that was that was a while
ago wasn't it they Struck it down uh I
think it was sort of struck down and
then it was kind of struck down again
because there was something about it
recently yeah again I didn't really pay
attention but like they're once again
legal yeah yes but I don't think anyone
will come out and start selling them or
putting in a gun broker or anything like
that because it's still kind of that
weird burnt child syndrome they're like
it's about a sock yep Trump Bandit don't
really want to do anything with it and
the same so the the real the real real
thing they're doing is when they say
pistol braces are banned people get rid
of them detach them stop selling them
out of the business and then they lose
and then people are like wow we don't
have any more right businesses that make
them go under SB is probably I mean I
mean they haven't been able to sell them
for the last you know a couple months so
it's two months of Revenue lost wow or
three months whenever that was
um and I had this conversation with them
they're the biggest brace the company
like that's literally how I got started
SP tactical and they said hey our goal
and this is what I really appreciate
about them they were actual zealots for
the cause and not just not just
capitalists but they're capitalists with
a conscience they said we would love to
put ourselves out of business by getting
sbrs taken off yeah so we don't have to
make these stupid things we'll pivot and
make stocks and we'll be fine so yeah
they they're probably uh two months out
of Revenue
um they're putting all their efforts
into the political fight there are
disabled people who can you who use them
yeah sure so you still do need pistol
braces yeah they'll make I mean they
definitely make a lot less but not as
much but yeah that's the thing like the
problem is
we will be honest about the fact that
people are using them as stocks I mean I
got tons of YouTube videos doing it so
the evidence is there and then but
because of that Honesty
our political Rivals will weapon out
like they will not be honest back
they'll they'll claim the AR-15 she
needs to be banned and then completely
ignore every other weapon and every
other you know whatever yeah well I
think that I think that's a lot of the
issue it's my issue and I've been
speaking about this for like the last
six years is gun owners sugarcoat like
the modern the modern sporting rifle is
a perfect example companies go well we
can't call it an M4 we can't call it a
weapon so we're gonna call it a sporting
rifle and that right there communicates
to people that oh this is a privilege
not a right yeah it's just a sporting
instrument it's for three gun or two gun
or Shooting Sports which people aren't
when the M P 15 in 2020 the M P 15 was
the best-selling rifle in the nation an
air 15 with a front sight post 16 inch
barrel people were not buying those to
shoot competitions we did not see a rise
in Shooting Sports USPSA multi-gun three
gun win all those rifles for getting
bought that's not why people are buying
them but companies go we're gonna call
it a sporting rifle so that we get some
heat taken off of us but all that does
is communicate to Gun Owners this is a
privilege not a right and it's going to
cause issues and I've literally told
companies like they've asked me hey what
should we do to modernize our brand a
little bit and I just go dump that name
get rid of it it's doing more harm than
good long term it might be fine right
now but in 10 years what's it going to
do to the culture and how people view
guns thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time